-Good evening, I'm Seth Meyers,
this is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
Former President Trump defended
his children, over the weekend,
against the New York State
Attorney General Letitia James'
lawsuit, and said, quote,
"Ivanka --
Ivanka is a very good person.
Don Jr., he's a good person.
Eric -- Eric --
these are good people."
So, if there's one thing --
one thing he's learned
from this lawsuit,
it's all of their names.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
President Biden initially
worried his student debt
forgiveness plan wouldn't
go over well
with working-class people,
and told his advisers, quote,
"The federal government
shouldn't be bailing out
Ivy League graduates."
I mean, at least not until
they become bank presidents.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, I got Bernie Sanders
backstage.
I'm going to play to him
a little bit, all right?
[ Laughter ]
At the Global Citizen music
festival in New York
over the weekend
House Speaker Nancy Pelosi
appeared to be booed
by the crowd.
To be fair, she completely
flubbed her solo.
[ Laughter ]
Florida governor Ron DeSantis
has warned of potential
evacuation orders
this week in advance of
Hurricane Ian.
The two aren't related, he just
loves kicking people out.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new book
about his business dealings,
former president Trump once
received a lease payment
in boxes of gold bricks
and asked his security guard,
Matthew Calamari,
to bring them to his Trump Tower
apartment.
Is it just me or does every
new Trump story sound
like a 9-year-old wrote
a mafia movie?
[ Laughter ]
[Mobster accent]
"Forget about it, Calamari.
This town belongs
to Johnny Pizza."
[ Laughter ]
[Normally]
House Republicans on Friday
announced their new
Congressional platform,
which featured a quote
misattributed
to Abraham Lincoln.
Apparently,
he never actually said
"Disney+ is grooming
our children."
[ Laughter ]
Kanye West appeared to comment
on his divorce
with Kim Kardashian in
an Instagram story yesterday
and said, quote, "London,
I know how you feel.
I lost my Queen too."
It's sweet that he thinks Kim
is a queen,
but weird that he thinks London
is a country.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, oh, well aren't you
the Queen of London?"
[ Light laughter ]
In an upcoming book, former
President Trump describes
"New York Times" reporter
Maggie Haberman
as his psychiatrist,
or that's just what he calls
any lady with glasses.
[ Light laughter ]
Former FBI director James Comey,
announced recently
that he will release
a mystery novel series.
Let me guess, Hillary did it?
[ Laughter ]
Or she didn't, or she maybe did,
but you're unclear about it?
A teen in Canada recently set
a Guinness world record
after putting 22 socks
on one foot in 30 seconds,
all because her father refuses
to let anyone
touch the thermostat.
[ Laughter ]
NYU will offer a new course
this fall
focused on singer Lana Del Rey's
music.
To qualify, you must have
completed at least two semesters
of Lexapro.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
according to a new survey,
more than half of Americans said
that they have muted themselves
during a virtual meeting
to pass gas.
Even worse,
the other half just didn't.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!